the jordan poster worth a fortune up  there i might have to buy this one  how much is this poster five would you  do three  cool i can't believe i'm [ __ ] buying  this thing son of a [ __ ] i'm so pissed  right now  why because i grew up a humongous knicks  fan and the prime years of the best  nick years in the 90s michael jordan  stopped me from winning a championship  i don't even want to touch it lou can  you come here and get it  i didn't want to grab it but i had to  get it business is business  guys i'm not proud of it but i had to  buy this vintage jordan massively huge  poster i mean i paid three bucks it's  probably worth 100 bucks in like a cool  soho store  in like a cool soho that's right